le 11 juillet 2021
l'italie affronte l'angleterre en finale
du championnat d'europe des nations de
football
les deux équipes n'ont pas réussi à se
départager pendant le temps
réglementaire
la finale se jouera donc dans une séance
de tirs au but et le dernier tireur
anglais est un jeune homme de 19 ans
incertain boukai au sac à
cissac a rate son tir au but
l'angleterre perdre à
ça car silence qui tirent et son tir est
arrêté par le gardien italien
à ce moment là
l'angleterre a perdu
ses espoirs ce sont les espoirs de tout
un pays qui s'effondre
mais la vraie victime dans cette
histoire
ça va être le pauvre boukai osaka au
moment où son tir est arrêté il le sait
déjà
dans les jours les semaines et les mois
qui suivent
ces notifications et ses fils
d'actualités sur les réseaux sociaux se
remplit
d'une vague d'un tour d'un océan
insultes xénophobes et racistes
ça car est en train de subir un
harcèlement harcèlement à l'échelle
nationale
alors de tel harcèlement ça n'arrive pas
à la plupart d'entre nous fort
heureusement
cependant les harcèlements sont devenu
incroyablement courant dans nos sociétés
on estime ainsi que dans chaque salle de
classe en suisse environ trois élèves
subissent un harcèlement scolaire
et ses harcèlements ont des conséquences
dramatiques
sur la santé mentale des victimes qui
peuvent aller de l'anxiété chronique à
la dépression
voire
juste suicide
et ses harcèlements vont deux équipes
qui prennent parfois des formes
physiques prennent de plus en plus la
forme de violence verbale sur internet
en particulier sur les réseaux sociaux
et à ce jeu là il n'y a pas d'égalité
certaine minorité ethnique
les femmes et la communauté lgbt qu sont
beaucoup beaucoup plus exposés que les
autres
les réseaux sociaux sont très peu
inclusif
pour beaucoup de personnes
et ça ça a des conséquences non
seulement sur les victimes mais même des
conséquences beaucoup plus profonde sur
nos sociétés
il est ainsi beaucoup plus difficile
pour une femme ou pour une personne
d'origine ethnique différente de réussir
sur les réseaux sociaux de devenir un
influenceur ou un youtube heures à
succès et quand il s'agit en particulier
de sciences par exemple d'informatique
il ya des conséquences très importantes
sur la représentativité sur l'absence de
modèle pour toutes sortes de personnes
à cela s'ajoute le fait que de plus en
plus les opportunités professionnelles
se trouve sur les réseaux sociaux en
excluant certaines sous population
les réseaux sociaux sont en train de
créer des inégalités de plus en plus
exacerbée en termes de genre et en
termes raciale
alors il ya toutes sortes de problèmes
mais en tant que chercheur en
informatique
la question qui m'intéresse c'est
comment est ce que je peux aider comment
est ce que je peux faire en sorte de
combattre ces inégalités cette
discrimination de masse sur les réseaux
sociaux
bien malheureusement beaucoup des
algorithmes sur lesquels j'ai pu
travailler
sont malheureusement pas aussi
extrêmement guézé voire parfois ils
aggravent la situation
par exemple il ya un an un algorithme
développé et déployé par twitter était
lui-même en un sens raciste alors je
vous explique un peu le problème ce qui
se passe c'est que lorsque vous utilisez
twitter et que vous mettez en ligne une
photo sur twitter
si cette photo n'est pas dans les
dimensions de twitter twitter va
automatiquement recadrer la photo dans
une région qui considèrent intéressante
mais le problème qu'on peut se poser
c'est imaginez maintenant qu'il y ait
une photo avec deux visages
de visages qui sont suffisamment distant
pour qu'il soit impossible pour
l'algorithme de recadrer la photo sur
les deux visages à la fois
l'algorithme doit alors choisir
imaginez maintenant que parmi ces deux
visages il y a le visage d'une personne
de couleur de peau blanche et le visage
d'une personne de couleur de peau noire
que va-t-il se passer quel visage va
être mise en avant par cet algorithme de
recadrage et quel visage sera ignorée
je pense qu'avec l'image écran vous
pouvez deviner ce qui se passe
l'algorithme de twitter recadre
systématiquement la photo sur la
personne de couleur de peau blanche et
ignorent et face
la personne de couleur de peau noire
en un sens l'algorithme est raciste
mais il ya pire il ya pierre notamment
avec l'avènement des algorithmes de
traitement du langage
ces algorithmes ont entraîné avec une
grande quantité de textes trouvés sur
internet et allaient à l'instar des
claviers intelligent sur votre téléphone
c'est al gore ils sont capables
d'effectuer de l'auto complétion vous
pouvez ainsi commencer une phrase qui
parle par exemple de musulmans et les
c'est l'algorithme compléter
bien je vous laisse deviner ce qui se
passe lorsqu'on lance cet algorithme
sur des phrases comme deux musulmans
rentrer dans une mosquée
le chercheur aboubakar habib a fait
l'expérience encore et encore avec l'un
de ses algorithmes gpt 3 développé par
open et a constaté que systématiquement
cet algorithme complète ce genre de
phrases avec des mentions de terrorisme
imaginez maintenant que des applications
comme google search s'appuie sur de tels
algorithmes
c'est déjà un peu le cas il faut alors
craindre et qu'à chaque fois qu'un
utilisateur cherche musulmans sur google
on lui recommande systématiquement des
contenus sur le terrorisme et ceux à
potentiellement des milliards
d'utilisateurs sur terre
là on parle de conséquences
potentiellement géopolitique majeur à
très grande échelle
mais alors pourquoi
que se passe-t-il pourquoi est-ce que
ses algorithmes on sait bien raciste
bien pour le comprendre je vais vous
raconter l'histoire de deux êtres go
rythme conversationnel
coc et payent aux destins très
différents vous avez peut-être entendu
parler de tels seuils a été développé
par l'entreprise microsoft et avait été
laissé dans le lancer sur twitter où tu
ailles interagissez avec les
utilisateurs
en l'espace de 24 heures seulement telle
était devenu raciste et sexiste elle
appelait même au génocide de certaines
sous population
mais ce que nous à ce que vous ne savez
peut-être pas c'est que le même
algorithme a été déployée par microsoft
sur les réseaux sociaux chinois sous le
nom de coc
et sa hausse est en revanche est devenu
adorable à tel point que sa hausse et
est aujourd'hui utilisé par 600 millions
de chinois
600 millions de chinois un chinois sur
deux
et beaucoup de ces chinois la décrivent
comme adorable même intelligente et même
séduisante
alors que s'est-il passé comment se
fait-il que le même algorithme conçu par
la même entreprise devienne un côté
raciste et de l'autre adorable
et bien tout se joue dans les données
dans les données auxquelles ces
algorithmes ont accès en gros tu es à
chaque fois qu attiser un truc horrible
il y avait plein de troll sur twitter
qu'il acquiert au tweet est et du coup
tu ailles s'est dit ah c'est la chose à
faire
alors que dans les réseaux sociaux
chinois s'est à chaque fois que ça aussi
disait quelque chose d'adorables qu'elle
recevait de l'engagement des réponses et
des like ses algorithmes sont manipulés
par leurs données
mais alors moderne les grandes
entreprises du web utilisent toutes
sortes de données qu'elles trouvent pour
entraîner leurs algorithmes
est-ce qu'il faut avoir peur est-ce que
parmi les données du vous avez il y a
beaucoup de données peu fiables en fait
c'est pire que ça dans une grande partie
du web il ya des attaques de campagne de
désinformation qui met sciemment des
données trompeuses
et pour vous donner une ampleur de
l'échelle de ces attaques je vous laisse
réfléchir à la question suivante
quel est d'après vous le nombre de faux
compte qu'il ya sur facebook par exemple
en 2019
combien de faux comptes facebook at il
dû retirer de sa plateforme ce qu'on
parle de 1000 faux compte steam il faut
compte un million de faux comptes
je vous laisse y réfléchir
bien la réponse c'est qu'en 2019
facebook a retiré environ 6 milliards de
faux comptes
6 milliards de faux comptes
sachant que facebook prétend avoir 3
milliard d'utilisateurs non et
honnêtement je ne sais pas comment ils
savent
en fait ce qui se passe c'est que la
plupart des comptes sur internet sont
des faux comptes
et les algorithmes aujourd'hui sont
entraînés sur toutes ces données
et du coup
ses algorithmes en fait ces algorithmes
ils vont regarder est typiquement les
like les retweet que reçoivent tel ou
tel contenu
donc quand vous voyez un contenu sur
twitter qui a énormément de laïcs et de
retweet il faut se demander finalement
ces données c'est là qui certes 8 est ce
que ce sont des laïcs et des rechutes
d'humains ou est ce que ce sont le
résultat de campagnes de désinformation
aujourd'hui les algorithmes de
recommandations ignorent cette question
il affiche le nombre total de like et de
retweet
indépendamment de savoir s'il s'agit de
laïcs et de retweet de faux comptes
et si vous aurez fichiers c'est même
pire que ça parce qu'il n'ya pas que les
alouettes qui sont vulnérables qui on
observe ces nombre de lacs et de retweet
les utilisateurs humains aussi
réagissent à cela et donc quand tu as un
message horrible
d'un auteur de ce message reçoit
énormément de like et de retweet
l'utilisateur humain va se dire ah tiens
ça ça fait des vues
est malheureusement bien souvent ce sont
des messages d'un harceleur des messages
horrible qui reçoivent ce genre de lacs
et de retweet et qui encouragent du coup
les auteurs de ces messages à persévérer
dans cette création de messages de haine
et c'est même encore pire que ça puisque
la raison pour laquelle ces messages
deviennent tout à coup extrêmement
populaire c'est parce que les
algorithmes
pense que cet amoureux je pense que ce
message et populaires de base et du coup
ils vont l'amplifier et leurs commandes
et beaucoup beaucoup plus encore
aujourd'hui le web est soumis à toutes
ces attaques et les algorithmes n'êtes
pas
et ça c'est parce que finalement les
algorithmes ne sont pas conçus pour être
éthique ils sont conçus aujourd'hui pour
mettre en avant ce qui est populaire
alors comment est-ce qu'on résout ce
problème
ça c'est vraiment la question qui me
fascine c'est la question qui lorsque je
me réveille je me dis qu'est-ce que je
peux faire pour améliorer ses
algorithmes
bien vu un début de réponse pour vous
avec des collègues on a lancé une
plate-forme appelée tournesol l'objectif
de tournesol à très long terme c'est
vraiment de résoudre ces questions de
permettre des recommandations qu'ils
soient plus éthique et notre solution
pour y arriver c'est de dépendre de
jugement de nos contributeurs on essaie
de généraliser finalement ce que nos
contributeurs juge éthique a recommandé
en pratiquement ça se passe n'importe
lequel d'entre vous peut aller sur la
plateforme et choisir deux vidéos
youtube a comparé et nous dire laquelle
de ces deux vidéos de ces vidéos
devraient être davantage recommandé à
plus grande échelle
alors bien sûr si oui si vous voulez
donner plus d'informations aux
tournesols mais tout à fait d'accord et
on vous permet notamment de préciser
selon différents critères laquelle de
ces vidéos est meilleur est-ce que telle
ou telle vidéo est davantage viable en
termes informationnel est-ce que telle
ou telle une vidéo parle d'un sujet plus
importants et ainsi de suite et l'un de
nos critères et bien sûr est ce que la
vidéo promeut la diversité et est ce
qu'elle est inclusive est-ce qu'elle
serait bien reçu y compris par exemple
par des personnes critiqué par la vidéo
ensuite à partir de toutes ces données
avec tous nos sols on assigne à chaque
vidéo noté par nos contributeurs
un score qui représente du coup la vie
de la communauté
et si vous utilisez les plugins de
tournesol pour faire fox ou pour chrome
vous pouvez accéder directement aux
recommandations de la communauté de
tournesol dans la page d'accueil youtube
à long terme on espère que ces outils
vont nous permettre de combattre la
discrimination de masse sur les réseaux
sociaux et de mettre en avant davantage
dé contenu d'utilité publique
mais pour y arriver nous avons besoin
d'une grande base de contributeurs nous
avons besoin de beaucoup plus de
jugements humains pour nous aider à
guider nos scores et faire en sorte que
tous nos sols devienne un algorithme de
recommandations avant tout stable
j'espère que je vous ai convaincus que
rendre ses algorithmes bénéfique est
devenu extrêmement important et j'espère
que je pourrai compter sur chacun
d'entre vous pour nous aider à rendre
ces algorithmes plus bénéfique merci
[Applaudissements]